scene will we reveal the stories behind
the headlines and for that we turn to
Fox News contributor Raymond aroyo all
right Raymond Biden he's hitting the
campaign Trail hard yeah I'm afraid it's
hitting back just as hard Laura
President Biden was campaigning in South
Carolina ahead of the weekend's primary
but it may have been wiser to just send
a statement instead there are still too
many corporations in America ripping
people off you see that article about
the Snickers
bars well it's going to stop
America we're tired of being played for
suckers let me tell you who else is
noticing that Donald
Trump did you see what he recently said
about that wants he wants to see the
economy crash this
year sitting
president he's a sitting president Laura
Donald Trump okay I don't even know
what's did I miss a story about snickers
and I love Snickers especially when
they're in the freezer take them out
freezer M those are good there there was
a piece in the New York Times about
inflation and Snickers and of course he
just reduced all of that to Snickers
it's going to stop okay on Sunday Biden
tried to reach out to Black voters by
claiming that he went to mass Laur and
then attended a black Baptist Church
things didn't improve much on Sunday
when he spoke to the church in South
colum in Colombia in South Carolina and
he told these old stories
watch you all think I'm kidding for the
longest time when I was a young public
defender and United States Senator I
went to if you don't excuse me am church
I apologize but all kiding aside then
I'd go to 10:30 Mass 10:30 service with
Reverend bean and uh you know uh you
said it rev my uh my mother would say
you got to be who you say you are yeah
well that's the problem Laura is he
being who he says he is 3 years ago he
claimed he went to 8:00 mass and then
attended a a church a Union Baptist
Church in Wilmington only no one there
remembers him ever attending that church
uh so this is a very tough moment for
the president trying to be who he's not
he needs divine intervention just to get
through these speeches at this point
well not only through them Laura if he's
so famili with the black church he might
have had an easier time figuring out how
to exit the pulpit he he really had a
difficult time here he doesn't know
whether to go left or right or genu fck
look here where do I do I do I go okay
yeah it looks like what's that Disney
the Disney Hall of Presidents is that
what it is he almost moves like those
figures he does he has that very stiff
yeah it's well and exits are a problem
you're right all right Ray last week
Biden visited with uh those union
workers and social media they lit up
with all these reports that Biden put
the hard hat on backwards yeah well the
website Snopes quickly rushed in
claiming this was false uh the internal
suspension they said on the helmet was
just sticking out well now they're
walking that back they've done an aout
face on the hard hat and we can now
verify Laura this is how you wear the
hat not like
this which that he's literally got it on
backwards it's where is I don't even see
him oh there he is he's there in the
middle he's I mean well he kind of looks
looks like a cardboard cutout there but
isn't that pathetic that you have to
that you have to actually go to Snopes
to get them to correct their correction
I mean it's just sad It's the newerk
reaction of the indefensive hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else